hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
at google cloud
in this video i want to introduce you to
kf as your team standardize on
kubernetes migrating applications from
existing platforms like cloud foundry
is often one of the biggest challenges
kf was designed to help teams minimize
any disruption to developer workflows
during the migration to google
kubernetes engine
and anthos
[Music]
kf offers developers the cloud foundry
experience while empowering platform
admins and operators
to adopt declarative kubernetes
practices
it makes migrating cloud foundry
workloads to kubernetes straightforward
and most
importantly avoids major changes to
application
developer workflows you can also
eliminate commercial cloud foundry
licensing costs
and take advantage of the config and
policy features of anthos and gke for
governance
before i show you a demonstration of kf
i wanted to talk a bit about the
architecture and how we map cloud
foundry primitives and services to
kubernetes
calf requires kubernetes and other open
source projects to run
some of the dependencies are satisfied
with google managed services
for example google kubernetes engine
provides the kubernetes back end
in addition to kubernetes kf leverages
techton to enable kf build
which can handle both build pack and
docker file builds
to take care of setting up routes for
applications kf uses antho service mesh
which is built on google's manage istio
offering
by default chaof includes native
integration with google cloud's cloud
monitoring and cloud logging services
this integration lets you monitor your
running clusters and help analyze your
system and application performance using
advanced profiling and tracing
capabilities
on the monitoring side kf has both an
application performance dashboard which
provides information on metrics such as
requests per second round-trip latency
http
error codes and more as well as a
systems dashboard which has data on
nodes
pods containers etc kf installs several
of its own kubernetes custom resources
and controllers
the custom resources effectively serve
as the kf api
and are used by the kfcli to interact
with the system
the controllers use kfcrds to
orchestrate the other components in the
system
you can view these resources using
kubectl
before we jump into our demo i want to
talk from just a minute about service
brokers
service brokers are software components
that provide an abstraction to manage
service life cycles across
different platforms kf supports service
brokers that are built according to the
open service broker specifications
currently
kf only supports credentialed services
special services such as syslog drains
volume services
route services service keys and shared
services aren't yet supported
in the demo i'll be using the cloud
service broker to provision a memory
store for redis instance
on that note let's jump into the demo
where i'll show you how to deploy the
spring music app to kubernetes
using kf as well as how to provision and
manage a google cloud-based redis
service
as the backing data store as we start
our demo i've actually
already set up my cluster running kf so
there are my nodes
and i've also already configured the
marketplace or the cloud service broker
so we're going to use this
redis service here later in the demo but
i just want to point it out right now
so the first thing we're going to do is
create a space to hold our app so i'll
create sm space for spring music space
and then we'll go ahead and target that
space
now if we do a kf spaces you can see the
space we just created
right there listed sm space the other
thing is
if we go in and we use cube ctl and we
say get spaces we can see the name space
for sm space so that's going back to
where
kubernetes primitives are being mapped
into kf primitives
so let's go ahead and push our app out
so we'll just do a kf bush we're already
in the directory with the repo
and that's going to go ahead and upload
the source and going to compile it it's
going to take a little bit
so i'll fast forward the video and i'll
rejoin you when it's done with the
application deployed let's go ahead and
visit it in the browser so clear the
screen i'll do a kf apps
and that will show me the route to the
application and i'm just going to go
ahead and grab
that url right here and we're going to
copy that and we're going to paste it
into
a new tab in our browser so i'll move up
here create a new tab paste that in
and there's our application running now
what i want to do is i want to come over
here and point out that we're not using
any profiles or services we're going to
add those in the next step
but i do want to add a record so i can
have something in the database so
i have this paul mccartney record i'll
scroll down and you can see that that
has been written to the local data store
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to go back and we're going to
connect redis into this
so let's move back into the command line
i'm going to clear the screen
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to issue the create service
command
and that's going to create that cloud
service backed
google redis database in a high
availability mode and connect it up to
our application in the spring music
space this is going to take a little bit
so i'm going to pause the video
and i'll come back to you when it's
finished all right the service has been
created
and if you look up here in the console
you can see here in google cloud where
we actually have created that
memory store with redis so now the next
step is to go ahead and bind that into
our application so let's do that right
now
so we'll clear the screen and then we'll
do a kf bind service
here and what we'll do is we'll bind the
spring music app to the redis database
we just created
and that'll take just a second and then
when that's done which it's done now
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to restart our application so we'll do a
kf
restart spring music that will allow
that new binding to take effect
so give that a second and then what
we're going to do is let's head back
into the web browser back into our
application
i'll refresh it and then we'll move over
here and you can see now that we're
using the redis profile and that redis
database
and if i scroll down the record that i
added to the local store is no longer
there because we're using the new
cloud-based
redis data store all right let's move
back
into the cloud console and i'm going to
show you just a couple more things
before we wrap up
so the first is kf bindings just so you
can see the service bindings here
and we'll list that out and you can see
that the database is bound to the
application
so i'll clear the screen again the other
thing i want to show you is that the
vcap services
are all listed out so that standard
methodology
for mapping services to apps is
available to you and there you have the
json for all of that
there you have it that's kf in a
nutshell now if you need more
information check out the links below
and don't forget to like and subscribe
so you'll be notified when we create new
[Music]
content
you